um before we talk about the election i
just want to ask you very quickly
about covid in scotland the decision was
taken to speed up the easing
of lockdown there are these concerns
about a new variant first identified in
india how concerned are you and are you
prepared to slow things down again if
necessary
well if necessary of course we have to
do that but i fervently hope it won't be
necessary we're making good progress
here case numbers are falling
at the vaccination rollout is going
exceptionally well but the big risk we
face
not just in scotland but across the uk
right now is the importation of new
variants
of the virus variants that might be
faster spreading that might be
more severe and crucially variants that
might undermine
the efficacy of the vaccine so we've got
to be very
very careful about that which is why i
think one of the restrictions we're all
going to have to live with for longer
is a restriction on international travel
in scotland
we insist that people quarantine in
managed isolation
at wherever in the world they come to if
they come directly
into scotland and we continue to try to
persuade the uk government to take a
similar approach
because we mustn't allow the progress
we're making domestically to be
undermined
by two lacks of position on
international travel it's very difficult
for the sector
and it's really important that
governments support it as we try to
continue to protect ourselves
against the virus we spoke to george
eustis a bit earlier on the program he
said that
at the moment there doesn't seem to be
evidence that the
variant first found in india is more
contagious
all that it evades the vaccine is that
your understanding as well
so far that would be my understanding
it is at the moment a variant of
interest as opposed to a variant
of concern but i think the thing we've
got to recognize about covid
is that it is mutating and we're seeing
new variants appear in different parts
of the world
the variant of course that has caused us
in
scotland and other parts of the uk the
most
problem over the last few months is the
the kent variant the one that
led us all into lockdown again over
christmas and into the early part of
this year
so we don't know where the variants of
real concern are going to come from
which is why an approach to
international travel that tries to
categorize risk with some countries
categorized as redless countries and
other countries deemed to be safer
i think poses a risk because none of us
know right now
where the next variant that might be
really problematic is going to
occur which is why unfortunately and i
take no pleasure in saying this because
it's really difficult for
the aviation sector reports tourism
we've got to be very careful as we
continue to suppress things at home
we've got to be careful we don't allow
it to be reseeded
with more dangerous variants from
elsewhere i mean if i look back to
last summer the later part of last
summer as we came out of the first
lockdown
we almost eliminated the strains that
were circulating within scotland here
but we probably opened up international
travel too quickly so we
allowed the virus to reseed into our
domestic population and i think it's
important we try as hard as we can
to avoid that in the weeks and months
ahead the importance of
learning the lessons from the previous
year
i'm keen to talk now a bit about your
domestic
record ahead of the all-important
elections coming
up in may and specifically just to start
on education
so in 2015 before the last election you
said
my priority as first minister and let me
be clear i want to be judged on this
is that every young person should have
the same advantage that i had
growing up now research from glasgow
university last year
found what it describes as staggering
inequality
in scotland schools pupils who live in
the most deprived fifth
of communities are just as likely to
leave school with just one hire
our students in the most prosperous
fifth leave with five
so does every scotland every child in
scotland have the same advantages as you
had growing up
not yet i think we've still got work to
do but more of those young people have
greater advantages now than was the case
five years ago and let me be clear i
will be judged on this as i will be
judged on
everything in just a couple of weeks
time at the election if you take the
attainment gap in particular and i know
the qualification system is different in
scotland to other parts of the uk so
apologies if i'm about to use
terminology that not everybody will
understand but
what we call level five which is our
national fives the attainment gap has
reduced by
a third at level six which is our
highers it has reduced by a fifth
there's work
to do we've expanded dramatically early
years education which everybody accepts
is the biggest investment you can make
in reducing the attainment gap later in
a young person's school education and we
also have now and
you know this is something that's
important to me as somebody who was the
first person in my family to go to
university
we now have record numbers of people
from poorer more deprived
communities going into higher education
so we've made significant progress
but we still got work to do we would
undoubtedly have made
more progress had we not faced
the disruption as everybody has faced
over the past year with covid so
there remains a lot of work to do and
one of the reasons i'm asking people to
re-elect me as first minister the snp as
government
is so that we can get on with that job
we're probably the only party in this
election
that is uh putting a serious plan for
government before the scottish people
you can't blame this all uh on the
pandemic though i did if you look at the
uh
but if you look at the statistics from
before the pandemic for example the pass
rate for her exam has gone down over the
last four years 79
in 2015 75 now i mean that's happening
on your watch isn't it
sorry just to be clear sophie i think
people listening to me would not have
heard me try to blame everything
uncovered equally
i think most people understand that
covet has an impact on every aspect
of our life but if you look across the
last five years
at all of the statistics what you see in
scotland
is increasing attainment so people at
young people coming out of school with
more qualifications and the attainment
gap reducing
and more young people particularly from
deprived communities going into
university and indeed going on to
positive destinations overall i am not
going to sit here
um and say that it is job done and i
think there is more to do nor am i going
to apologize for
setting big ambitions and saying to
people judge me
on the record of my government overall
people will make a balanced judgment on
whether they think the snp
has a good record in government and the
evidence suggests that people don't
think we're perfect but people think
we're the party to be trusted
with taking scotland forward and they'll
look at the other parties as well
one of the interesting features of the
scottish election is that the other
parties are all vying
to be leader of the opposition in these
really serious times
scotland deserves a party that is
serious about government
serious about facing up to the
challenges of government leading us
through the crisis and into recovery and
that's what i and the snp
offer okay is the s p a party that is
serious about funding the nhs because
this week you promised a
transformational increase in nhs funding
the ifs says that actually the rise is
less than the rise planned for england
and it's actually unlikely to keep up
with demand so is the rhetoric better
than the reality here
can i come on to that in a moment
because i want to take that on directly
and
i think it's wrong but you know this is
one
area where i don't need to ask people to
judge me on what i'm promising for the
future
it judge me on the past so at the last
scottish election
i made a commitment that we would
increase funding in the national health
service by
500 million pounds in real terms
in reality we've done three times that
at the nhs budget over the past five
years has increased by
uh 1.8 billion pounds in real terms so
you know what you're promising
now and you promised a transformational
increase in nhs funding
this works out as 2.1
above inflation in england it's 3.4
percent and i
can i come on to that point but i think
i actually think it is it is legitimate
to say to people look
you you have pitched these questions out
look at my record so
i'm pointing to the record where we
actually exceeded the commitment we made
but on that point the ifs have looked at
the position
so there's two points to make here the
ifs have looked at the position in
england
up to 2023 that's the only uh
the time frame in which the uk
government have made a commitment in
england the commitment i've made for the
next parliament takes us up to 2026 so
it's
apples and pairs to make the comparison
that you have made but the other point
and this is a key point
is that in a sense the commitment i have
made is a backstop
whatever the budgetary position that the
uk government
delivers for scotland we will deliver
that transformational 20
increase in health funding but if the uk
government exceeds that
and that is extra money comes through
the barnet formula we will
commit that to the nhs as well so by
definition
we cannot be spending less than the uk
government does
in england because the commitment we've
made is the backstop and if
the barnett formula allows us to go
further we will go further but you know
we
exceeded our commitment at the last
election and we will deliver this
commitment
at least over the next parliament a 20
increase in nhs funding which amounts to
2.5
billion pounds extra money for social
care over and above that which the ifs
analysis also doesn't take into account
and
also shifting the balance of investment
so much more is going into community
health care
and mental health care too okay um
another area
i'm keen to talk about as well is drugs
scotland suffers more drug deaths per
capita than any other
european country over 1200 people dying
of drug you misused last year
that's a record high for the sixth year
in a row how is that acceptable it's not
um and i've been very candid about that
we
have tried to tackle the drugs deaths
but we can't look at the figures for the
numbers of people
dying and conclude that what we have
done has been
enough or has been effective enough so
over the past few months we've done a
number of things
to make a concerted attempt to turn this
around so firstly
i have appointed a dedicated minister
with
responsibility for this reporting
directly
to me we have set aside a budget over
the next few years
of 250 million pounds to specifically
support initiatives
to tackle the drugs crisis and drugs
deaths and that is supporting more
community work it is supporting greater
provision of rehabilitation beds
including residential rehabilitation and
after-care support faster access to
treatment so that if somebody comes
forward
looking for treatment they get that
quickly and aren't
having to wait for that so there is a a
whole package
of policies and interventions now that
we are taking forward to turn it around
because to be frank it's not
acceptable and you know you can make
choices as a politician you can be
confronted with something like that and
try to dig your heels in and defend
the indefensible or you can do what i
think is better and
admit that this is an area where we have
not done well enough and we're
determined to do better in future
you see it sounds very good what you're
promising it sounds very candid it
sounds like
you know you're very keen to point out
what you want to change in the future
but people will be wondering where has
this been over the last 14 years that
the snp has been in power
when there's been a 160 rise in drug
deaths
and a 55 cut in real terms funding for
alcohol and drug services is it too late
look we didn't get it right it's not
because we didn't care it's not because
we weren't
trying to do things but you know we have
concluded
because i don't think we can do anything
else that we haven't got it right now i
could sit here and i could
try to set out some of the reasons why
scotland may have a higher
number of drugs deaths in other
countries uh reasons that go back
many decades in some respects are having
your higher drug use
in the days when i was growing up an
older drug using population with
multiple morbidities i could see all of
that and some of that would
you know be legitimate and and be part
of the explanation but i'm choosing
instead to say
we haven't done well enough here we
haven't yet
uh implemented the the policies that
have turned us around so we're going to
redouble
our efforts we're going to try different
things now i could also sit here and say
that
aspects of the the levers over this are
reserved so the classification of
drugs whether or not we can have safe
consumption rooms which is something
most experts in scotland want to see uh
the
the levers of control of these things
still lie with westminster we don't have
all of the levers in our own hands now i
could say all of that
and all of that would have some
legitimacy but i'm actually choosing
instead to take
responsibility for not having done well
enough and for setting out
in great detail what we're going to do
to put it right i hope in future
i've been keen you know in the interview
to look back at your record
in government because it really matters
because you're effectively asking the
scottish people to trust you
to lead an independent scotland so it
really
matters you're clearly an exceptional
communicator you're clearly somebody who
has strong approval ratings relative to
other politicians
but if you look at the facts record drug
deaths after 14 years of an s p
government still
inequalities in education although you
admit
that in in some areas there's been
improvement there are still big
inequalities when it comes to education
the highest rate of care home resident
deaths from covered in the uk
why should people trust you to lead an
independent scotland
sorry sophie the number of care home
deaths in scotland is far too high and
it shouldn't be a statistical
competition
but i really do have to challenge that
the number of
excess deaths in k homes in england has
been much higher
than in in scotland or higher than in
scotland
in scotland we have recorded more of
them as as
coveted death so i will challenge that
but that is not
saying that it is not the case that the
number of covered deaths and care homes
the number of covered deaths overall
uh hasn't been too high because it has
been like
people will decide whether they trust me
or not that's what elections
are all about i'll put my record in
front of the people of scotland i'll
point to all of the things
that we have done over the past term of
parliament we have
established a new social security system
in scotland we've established
a scottish child payment which is
lifting children out of poverty at the
level of child poverty too high
but lower in scotland than in any other
part of the uk
we have made progress in closing the
attainment gap we've led the country
through the covered pandemic i'll also
be candid
with people because i think it's better
to do that than the opposite
about where i think we haven't got
things right or where we have
more work to do and then people will
make a judgment about who they
trust most to lead the country through
covet
to get us into recovery and we put
before the scottish people a bold
ambitious
transformative program for recovery from
covid
and then after covert when the time is
right to decide
the future of scotland whether we should
leave big decisions in the hands of
politicians like boris johnson or
whether we should take those decisions
into our own hands as an independent
country so that we can
shape the long-term future of scotland
in the way we want it to be and and
people will make their judgments about
that they'll look at me my record what i
offer people
and they'll look at the opposition and
the competition as well and they'll
cast their verdict on may the 6th that's
democracy and i embrace it thoroughly
um alex salmond has launched a new party
to help build a supermajority for
scottish independence you must be very
grateful for his help
look he can speak for himself we need a
simple majority
in the scottish parliament to give us
the mandate for an independence
referendum and then of course we need a
majority of the scottish people to win
independence and you know when i listen
to people who talk about super
majorities they sound as if they think
we can just build those our way to
independence which is almost
contemptuous
uh towards those that we need to
persuade
the many many people have been acting
them i
i listen to the the rhetoric around
independence and it seems to skip
over they need to do the hard work of
persuading those who voted no in 2014
many of whom are now open-minded i know
many of these people but
want to be persuaded and want to be
treated with respect and want
us to make a convincing persuasive case
to them and
that's the hard work that i've been
doing polling for independence is at a
higher level now than it's ever been
but we've got to continue with that hard
work with that respectful
discourse and that's how we win
independence and you know i'm not
particularly interested in
an arm wrestling contest with other
people about who supports independence
the most
that's a conversation with ourselves i'm
interested in persuading those who are
open-minded but need still to be
persuaded so that we build a majority
for independence that then expresses
itself in a legitimate process
because that's how we win independence
and that's what i want to do
in the spirit of respectful discourse if
alba does win seats at the election
would you
work with alex salmond no i'm not going
to work with alex almond uh
firstly i have concerns about his
personal conduct that he hasn't
acknowledged or
apologized for as i've just said i i
don't
agree with the approach to independence
because i think it is
more or it is risking putting people off
rather than bringing people towards us
there's no shortcut to independence
we've got to do it through
winning a majority and allowing that
majority to express itself in a
legitimate process i also
don't know what albus stands for for me
independence is not an end in itself
it's
a means to a better scotland a fair uh
equal scotland where we value everybody
who lives here
for who they are and i don't know what
albus stands for but
from what i've seen so far i i probably
would have some concerns about that
okay um just finally we talked a lot
about lobbying
on the programme this morning the snp
minister fergus ewing had a dinner
with lex grunsel and sanjeev gupta in
2017. this is according to the sunday
mail
no officials were there no notes were
taken
if there's no record of what happened
how do we know it's above board
well it was recorded in the usual way in
the the register of
meetings look i understand the
temptation to draw an analogy between
the the scandal that we see developing
around david cameron
around the uk government and the
scottish government is dealing with gfg
the two things are very different we
work directly with gfg to firstly
uh save the dl steel works in 2015 there
was virtually nobody employed there
today it employs more than 100 people
and secondly with that company to save
the loca
aluminium smelter and you know there's
more than 100 jobs have been protected
there with more created as a result the
guarantee that was agreed
uh to support uh that takeover of the
smelter the committee of the scottish
parliament approved that
so it's not the the lobbying scandal
that we see elsewhere and i think people
should be careful
in trying to draw that analogy with all
the proper due diligence has been done
things like the the way in which green
cell has tried to to use the nhs
which david cameron allegedly lobbied
for that's not happened
in scotland and we've not had you know
some of the stuff around
covered loans so i can see the
temptation but the two things are not
the same